[Music]
this is the oldest the driest and the
highest non-polar desert in the world
according to nasa the atacama is the
closest thing on earth to the rugged
arid terrain of planet mars
long stretches of the atacama desert are
located on south america's andes
highlands at over 4 000 meters above sea
level
llamas and guanacos are at home here
despite extreme temperatures that can
drop to -10 degrees
but for undocumented migrants it's one
of the most treacherous environments on
earth
we find this small group of young
venezuelans who've just made the journey
across the bolivian border into chile
you can die trying to get here the cold
is indescribable we had to leave two
others behind they may not make it
i thought i wouldn't survive i couldn't
breathe
it's a 5 000 kilometer journey from
venezuela to colombia then ecuador down
to peru and then from bolivia into chile
the final
destination it took me almost five
months to get here i was robbed and had
to walk from peru
they're grateful for the bag of fruit
we're able to give them they say they've
had nothing to eat for at least three
days and almost no water or money so
they keep walking in the direction of
chile's capital santiago another two
thousand kilometers south
this is another telltale sign that
migrants have passed by here it looks
like they came here for shelter spent
the night in this adobe
dwelling that's used by the sheepherders
the llama herders during the spring and
the summer what they did after that was
to start getting rid of what they were
carrying and we see this all along the
road because there's simply too
exhausted to carry their things any
longer
seventeen-year-old jorge has only kept a
sheet his feet are cracking from walking
so much
at the first chilean border town called
chaney dr guillermo tapia is on call 24
hours a day
many of the migrants are asthmatic which
causes difficulty in breathing at this
altitude add acute dehydration and
intense cold they end up with
hypothermia we have seen multiple deaths
caused by it at the end the victim
starts taking off his or her claws
thinking they are not hot instead of
freezing
but there are other hazards apart from
robbery many migrants who can't pay
traffickers or bolivian police to allow
them to cross into chile say they've
been victims of sex abuse
once here the danger isn't over either
says colonel andres arenas
smugglers locked up a group of 49
venezuelans who couldn't pay in a house
190 kilometers from here we found them
last week thanks one of the victims the
child who called his mother who in turn
alerted us the traffickers by the way
were venezuelans themselves
the route is becoming a magnet for
criminals to prey on undocumented
migrants who are not legally allowed to
be in chile
yet they keep coming driven by
desperation to make money to send to
those left behind at home
it's like a gold rush with no guarantee
that the risk will be worth it
lucia newman al jazeera called chaney
chile